[Music]
I think that the word history is a lot
more demanding of us than we think
we spend much of our time dwelling in
things that aren't history we have
notions of the way time flows that are
comfortable but basically wrong and
allow us to sleepwalk and drift away
from what's actually confronting us and
what we should actually be seen in
feeling one of those is what I call the
politics of inevitability or for short
we could call it progress and that's the
idea that we know the rules of history a
is always going to lead to be the
world's pretty good as it is and that's
only it's only going to get better that
idea has been very present in the u.s.
in the form of history is over there are
no alternatives liberal democracy is
inevitable the markets just going to
bring about democracy so there's nothing
that we really have to do and of course
that's a core problem this kind of
thinking takes you out of history and it
says you're not responsible what you do
as an individual doesn't really matter
very much now the problem with that
they're one of many problems is that
eventually you're going to get some kind
of a shock you might get shocked in 2008
when you figure out you can't own a
house or you might get shocked in 2016
when somebody don't expect when it's a
presidential election but something's
gonna happen in your life which is gonna
shock you and suddenly this story about
inevitability about progress that's no
longer to make sense to you and then
you're gonna be vulnerable to what I
call the politics of eternity which is
another way of dwelling in time which
isn't history and the politics of
eternity we say it's not my fault I'm an
innocent victim everything which is
wrong comes from enemies from the
outside those others those enemies over
and over again come for us attack us try
to penetrate us hurt us and history then
just becomes a cycle we're over and over
and over again the innocent people are
attacked by by the bad guys basically
and then the politics of eternity what
also happens is that the news cycle the
daily cycle overwhelms you and it
instructs you who you're supposed to be
afraid of how you're supposed to feel
so the danger that when right now in the
u.s. is we're shifting from a politics
of inevitability to a politics of
eternity and it along the way we won't
notice how we're in history you know
history demands of us that we understand
that it's not inevitable to become
better it's also not inevitable become
worse there are certain structures and
what we do within those structures
matters and what history teaches us is
what those structures our that the
Europeans have a different politics of
inevitability so the structure is the
same the overall structure is that
things are pretty good they're going to
get better there are rules to history we
know those rules are there for it
doesn't matter what we what we do but
the particulars are very different the
European myth goes something like this
European nations are old European
nations are wise European nations learn
from the Second World War that war was a
bad thing and therefore cooperate
economically to form this thing called
the European Union now that's completely
false it's it's just as bogus as the
American idea that the markets gonna
bring about capitalism and there are no
alternatives not a word of that European
story is true even though pretty much
all Europeans believe in it European
nations are not old European nation
states have generally not really existed
the whole story of European history is
actually empires breaking apart and the
fragments of those empires coalescing in
this unit called the European Union
there's never really a moment in both
case in most cases where there was
actually a nation-state deciding for or
against Europe in fact empires shatter
their bloody wars if Europeans learn
anything it's that colonial wars are a
bad thing and then at that point you
dodge the difficulty and even the
atrocity of those lost colonial wars and
you start telling yourself this story
about how your Europeans and your
peaceful you boys have the nation-state
etc why does that matter
it matters because if you believe that
nonsense then you might think oh we can
go back to the nation-state we can go
back to France like the fullness when L
says or we can have breakfast and go
back to the United Kingdom the problem
with that is that France and the United
Kingdom have only ever existed either as
empires or as part of a European
integration project they've never
actually existed as nay
in states which means that going back to
them actually means jumping off into a
future that you have no idea about so
the European politics of inevitability
is this story about
the wise nation that's this fable of the
wise nation which chose Europe because
it's so wise that implies that Europeans
could now choose not to be in Europe
right but the thing is there never
really was a nation-state so the
European politics of eternity says
France was always innocent the British
roy's innocent the Germans the Russians
the poles the Hungarians we were always
innocent and maybe now we'd like to go
back to a place which in fact never
actually existed I think in the u.s. the
the politics of inevitability at least
from me is meant as a general critique
there are there are different versions
on the right and on the left and maybe
the version on the right is a little
more powerful the right-wing version the
politics of inevitability says the
markets everything government should be
weak because the markets gonna
automatically bring about good outcomes
even if it doesn't look like it's
bringing about good outcomes and some
secret you know in some secret way like
god it's mysteriously bringing about
good outcomes but there's a left-wing
version - there's a left-wing version
which is that the arc of history is long
but it bends towards justice which are
very powerful words uttered by both
Martin Luther King and Barack Obama many
what I find when I when I say that
that's a myth it hurts people but it is
a myth there's no arc of history there's
no shape of history at all
history is an accumulation of structures
that that come to us from behind and are
around us now and history is what we do
inside those structures there's no arc
one way or the other but the way the way
that things are breaking now in the u.s.
is that our politics of inevitability
which we've held to in the last 25 years
basically this idea that since communism
ended in 1989 there are no alternatives
basically this idea that technology must
lead to enlightenment this idea that the
market must lead to democracy those
ideas have now come back to clobber us
of them ever had any foundation both of
them are highly persuasive to a lot of
people and that's led to some
consequences which are very dangerous
for the rule of law and indeed for
democracy believing that for example
more market means more democracy means
that you don't regulate things that you
really need to regulate like offshore
wealth or anonymous transactions or or
shell companies and that creates a world
a gray zone of capitalism where for
example a Donald Trump can begin close
relationships with Russian oligarchs if
you believe that technology
automatically leads to progress then you
don't watch very carefully as certain
kinds of social platforms lead people
into a politics of us and them and
destroy a sense of common factual 'ti
the story that you're telling yourself
the whole time about how the market or
attack have to lead towards
enlightenment of democracy
dulls your mind to what's actually
happening until you reach the point that
we that we've reached now
[Music]